Ну ми стоїмо під апеляційним судом на
площі соломінській тут мав би відбутися
о 12 годині суд апеляційний над романом
червінським де ми мали Надії оскаржити
його отримання під вартою вже четвертого
місяця поспіль без права бачитися зі
своїми рідними є патріотами закривають
за фальши
вим
саме за те що він впродовців
розслідувати злочини нинішньої влади і
очільників різних відома в тому числі і
офісу президента але ми приїхали сюди і
в результаті суд замінований
суддів
полтавських
збройні рішення про то що тримання під
вартою продовження тримання під вартою
там по деяких справах які вони
продовжували це є незаконний Україна має
виплатити тим людям кошти яких вони
продовжували цетримання під вартою не
слухається питання в суді по суті справи
слухається лише запобіжний захід але
дивіться минуло Уже понад три місяці
і вже чотири місяці скоро і
суспільство наче уже закінчили уже
висунули підозру але слідчих дій не
ведеться а людину тримають за ґратами
потім ми бачимо з вами ситуацію коли так
зване замінування може призвести до або
перенесення засідання або чергове
відтермінування яке за собою тягне те що
буде перебувати за гратами
достатньо відома людина серед розвідки
товариства а Отже ця несправедливість
Має отримати нашу реакцію з вами
розуміємо що це Помста за справу в
Англії це ніби Дуже хотілось би все ж
таки наші партнери і народні які мають
моральне право навіть не публічно
говорити про те що ми допомагаємо і ми
спільно в одному човні Але ми теж бачимо
які ознаки недемократичні вже є
всередині країни
але в час війни Влада переслідує
відповідальність учасників патріотичних
українських офіцерів які просто чесно
виконують свої обов’язок
суспільство це демотивує армію і вже
саме по собі цей злочин і ми маємо
зробити все щоб все ж таки ми
перетворилися в єдину країну де Влада
опозиція патріоти стоять плечем до плеча
у боротьбі з ворогом а не розпалюють
всередині ворожнечу з тими хто найбільше
доклався і докладається і продовжує
докладатися до нашої Перемоги також це
Помста за те що він відверто і відкрито
назвав керівників офісу президента
людьми які зірвали спецоперацію із
виманювання в Україні арешту вакнерів
які потім за кілька років прийшли в
Україну і здійснювали уже нові і нові
злочини під бахмутом Всі казали про
слова свої підтримки всі окулі от тим що
відбувається у Баладі і якщо ми всі
готові до 70 хлопців
всередині і вона є одним із тих скажемо
так поштовхів які мене заставив приїхати
хоча після наребітації після операції
приїхати сюди і підтримати червінською а
в його лиці підтримати тих людей які
зараз зазнають так само їх імена можливо
менше відомі так само потерпають від
свавілля влади і протів які знаходяться
на мою думку знаходяться Барселона влади
які виконують замовлення ФСБ але я тут
хочу бачити більше людей і тому я дуже
прошу поставте собі галочку на часі дуже
на часі захищати наших військових Тобто
ми можемо десь там попускати в якихось
адміністративних чи в якихось там
корупційних справах бо війна і треба нам
зараз виборювати перемогу але попускати
захист військових Ми не маємо права вони
наша гарантія на життя їхній бій їхня
правда їхнє слово є гарантія майбутнього
нашої Української держави а якщо ви не
можете прийти на черговий суд чи до
червінського чи до марченка чи до
Антоненка чи до мене з марусією звіробій
чи по прямому зрештою чи вдо будь-кого
іншого зараз несправедливо переслідують
зробіть пости поширюйте інформацію зараз
розголос і гласність - це єдине що
впливає реально на ситуацію
[музика]